Every year, more than 100 countries send 6
of their brightest teenagers, or the occasional
pre-pubescent prodigy, to represent them in
the International Math Olympiad, commonly
known as the IMO.
Considering that each country has its own
elaborate system of contests leading to their
choice of 6 representatives, the IMO stands
as the culminating symbol for the surprisingly
expansive and wonderful world which is contest
math.
The contest is essentially a test, split over
two days, with three questions given over
four and a half hours each day.
The questions are all proofs, meaning you
don’t simply find some numerical answer,
you have to discover and articulate a rigorous
line of reasoning to answer each difficult
question, and they are scored on a scale from
0 to 7.
Of interest to us today is the one from 2011,
with 563 total participants representing 101
countries.
I know what your thinking, and the answer
is yes.
Those do all happen to be prime numbers.
But that’s not why this test was interesting,
out of these prime problem solvers, only one,
Lisa Saurmann from Germany, got a perfect
score.
The only thing standing between the next two
runners up and a perfect score that year was
problem #2.
This problem is beautiful, and despite evading
many of the world’s best mathematicians
of their age, the solution is something which
anyone watching this video can understand.
So let’s begin by reading it carefully.
“Let S be a finite set of at least two points
in the plane”
Mmkay, as you read a question it’s often
helpful to start drawing out an example for
yourself.
“Assume that no three points of S are collinear”
In other words, you never have three points
that line up.
So you can probably predict that the problem
involves drawing lines here in a way where
three points on one line would mess things
up.
“A windmill is a process that starts with
a line l going through a single point P in
S. The line rotates clockwise about the pivot
P until the first time that the line meets
some other point belonging to S”.
Again, while reading it’s helpful to draw
out an example, so we’ve got this line pivoting
around some point until it hits another.
“This point, Q, takes over as the new pivot,
and the line now rotates clockwise about Q,
until it next meets a point of S. This process
continues indefinitely”.
Alright, that’s kind of fun.
We keep rotating and changing the pivot.
You can see why they call it a windmill process,
and you can also see why they specified that
no three points lie on one line.
You wouldn’t want to run into the ambiguity
where you don’t know what pivot to switch
to.
Okay, so what’s the question?
“Show that we can choose a point P in S
and a line l going through P such that the
resulting windmill uses each point of S as
a pivot infinitely many times.”
Depending on your tolerance of puzzles for
puzzles’ sake, you might wonder why anyone
would care about such a question.
There’s a very good reason: I’d argue
that the act of solving this will make you
better at math and other related fields, which
I’ll explain once you’ve seen the solution.
But certainly on it surface this feels disconnected
from other parts of math.
Other Olympiad problems involve some function
to analyze, or a numerical pattern to deduce,
or perhaps a difficult counting setup or an
elaborate geometric construction, but problem
2 is an unusually pure puzzle.
In some ways, that’s its charm: proving
that some initial condition will result in
this windmill hitting all points infinitely
many times doesn’t test if you know a particular
theorem, it tests if you can find a clever
perspective.
But that blade cuts both ways; without resting
existing results from math, what could someone
possibly study that would prepare them to
solve this?
In fact, this brings us to the second unusual
thing about this problem: Based on the results,
I’m guessing it turned out to be much harder
than the contest organizers expected.
You see, typically, the three problems in
each day are supposed to get progressively
harder.
They’re all hard, of course, but problems
1 and 4 should be doable, problems 2 and 5
should be challenging, and problems 3 and
6...well they can be brutal.
But take a look at how many of the 563 participants
that year got perfect scores on each problem:
Only 22 got a perfect score for this question
number 2.
By contrast, 170 got a perfect score on problem
5, which is supposed to be about the same
difficulty, and more than twice as many, got
a perfect score for problem 3, which is supposed
to be harder.
You might notice that only six students got
full points for problem 6 that year, so by
some measure that was the hardest problem
on the test.
In fact, the way I introduced things earlier
was a little disingenuous, the full data would
suggest problem 6 was the real clincher.
But what’s strange is if you look at the
results of the only six students to solve
problem 6, all of whom are clearly phenomenal,
world-class problem solvers, this windmill
puzzle evaded five out of six of them.
But again, this problem is hard not hard because
of the background knowledge it demands, it
asks only for insight.
So how do you approach something like this?
The first step with any puzzle like this is
simply to play around to get a feel for it,
and it’s always good to start simple and
slowly get more complicated from there.
The simplest case would be two points, where
the line trades off between each point, so
that works well enough.
Adding a third point, it’s pretty clear
the line will just rotate around all of them.
It might not be entirely clear how you’d
phrase that as a rigorous proof yet, but right
now you’re just getting a feel for things.
The fourth point is where things get interesting.
In some places, your windmill will go around
the four points as it did with the triangle,
but if we put it inside that triangle, then
it looks like our windmill never hits it.
Looking back at the problem, it’s asking
you to show that for some starting position
of the line, not any position, the process
will hit all the points infinitely many times.
So for an example like this, if you start
with the line going through that troublesome
middle point, what happens?
And again, at this point you're just playing
around, perhaps moving your pencil among dots
you’ve drawn on your scratch paper, questions
of rigor and proof will come later.
Here you’d see that your windmill does indeed
bounce off all the points as it goes through
a cycle, and it ends up back where it started.
The worry you might have is that in some large
set of points, where some are kind of inside
the others, you might be able to start off
on the inside, but maybe the windmill process
takes the line to the outside, where it will
be blocked off from those inner points.
If you play around, and it might take some
time to draw out many examples and think this
through, you might notice that when the line
starts off passing the middle of all your
points, it tends to stay there; it never seems
to venture off to the outside.
But can you guarantee that this always happens?
Or rather, can you first make this idea of
starting off in the middle more rigorous,
and from there, prove that all points will
be hit infinitely many times?
As a general problem-solving tip, whenever
you have a vague idea that feels productive,
find a way to be more exact about what you
mean, preferably putting numbers to it, then
ask questions about those numbers.
In our example, one way to formalize the idea
of a “middle” is to count how many points
are on either side of the line.
If you give the line some orientation, you
can reasonably talk about the left half, say
coloring all points to the left of it blue,
and the right half, coloring all points to
the right of it brown, and what it means for
the line to be in the middle is that there
are as many blue points and brown points.
For the moment, let’s say the total number
of points is odd, and the point the line passes
through is colored white.
So for example, if there were 11 points, then
you’d have five blue ones on the left of
the line, and five brown ones on the right
of the line, and the one white one at the
pivot.
The case with an even number of points will
be similar, just slightly less symmetric.
This gives you a new question to ask: What
happens to the number of blue points and brown
points as the process plays out?
In the example shown, you might notice that
it’s always 5 and 5, never changing.
Playing with other examples, you’d find
the same is true.
Take a moment to pause and see if you can
think about why that would be true.
Well, the key is to think through what happens
as a line changes its pivot.
Having given the line an orientation, we can
talk about which half of the line is “above”
the pivot, and which is “below”.
If the line hits a blue point to its left,
it must happen below the pivot, so as it changes
pivots and continues rotating clockwise, the
old pivot, now above the new one, ends up
to the left of the line, in the blue region.
And entirely symmetrically, when it hits a
brown point, it happens above the pivot, meaning
that old pivot ends up in the brown region.
So no matter what, the number of points on
a given side of the line can’t change.
When you lose a blue point, you gain a new
one; when you lose a brown point, you also
gain a new one.
Great, that’s insight #1.
Now why would this imply that the line must
hit every point infinitely many times, no
matter what weird set of points you dream
up?
Well, think about letting this process go
until the line has turned 180 degrees.
That means it’s parallel to its starting
position, and because it has to remain the
case that half the points are on one side,
half are on the other, it must be passing
through the same point it started on.
Otherwise, if it ended up on some other point,
it would change the number on a given side.
Additionally, since the line has rotated halfway
around, everything that was blue has become
brown, and everything which was brown has
become blue, and the only way to change color
is if you get hit by the line.
So for our odd number case, that means that
after a half rotation, the line is back to
where it started having hit all the other
points.
So as time moves forward, it repeats that
exact same set of motions over and over, hitting
all points infinitely many times.
If there are an even number of points, we
need to alter the scheme slightly, but only
slightly.
Let’s say that in that case, the pivot counts
as a brown point.
So we can still select an initial point so
that half the points are blue, all on the
left, and half are brown, now either meaning
their either on the right or the pivot.
The same argument applies that after a 180-degree
turn, all the points will have swapped color,
although this time the line might be passing
through a different point after that first
half turn, specifically one that used to be
blue.
But after another 180 degrees the line must
be passing through the same point it started
on.
Why?
Again, it must be parallel to its starting
position, and if it was passing through any
other point, the number of points on a given
side would be different.
So again, you have a cycle which hits all
points, and which ends in the same position
where it started, so it must hit all points
infinitely many times.
There are two important lessons to take away
from this puzzle, the first social, the second
mathematical.
Once you know this solution and turn it about
in your head a couple times, it’s very easy
to fool yourself into thinking the problem
is easier than it is.
Of course the number of points on a given
side stays constant, right?
And of course when you start in the middle,
every point will switch sides after a half-turn,
right?
But the advantage of this problem coming from
the IMO is that we don’t have to rest on
subjective statements, we have the data to
show that this is a genuinely hard problem,
in that it evaded many students are demonstrably
able to solve hard problems.
In math, it’s extremely hard to empathize
with what it feels like not to understand
something.
I was discussing this video with a former
coworker of mine from Khan Academy who worked
a lot on their math exercises, and he pointed
out that across the wide variety of contributors
he’d worked with, there was one constant.
No one can tell how difficult their exercises
are.
Knowing when math is hard is often way harder
than the math itself.
This is important to keep in mind when teaching,
but it’s equally important to keep in mind
when being taught.
On are windmill puzzle, even if counting the
number of points on one side seems obvious
in hindsight, you have to ask, given the vast
space of possible things to consider, why
would anyone’s mind ever turn to this particular
idea?
This brings us to the mathematical takeaway.
What ultimately led to the solution was finding
something about this complex system which
stays constant during its chaotic unfolding.
This is a ubiquitous theme through math and
physics.
We’re finding what’s called an “invariant”.
Topologists do this when the count the holes
in a surface, physicists do this in defining
the ideas of energy and momentum, or in special
relativity when they define proper time.
As a student, it’s easy to take for granted
the definitions handed down to us, but the
more puzzles you solve where the insight involves
an invariant, the more you appreciate that
each of these definitions was once a clever
discovery.
Terence Tao, one of the greatest modern mathematicians
and the world’s youngest IMO medalist, wrote
that “Mathematical problems, or puzzles,
are important to real mathematics (like solving
real-life problems), just as fables, stories,
and anecdotes are important to the young in
understanding real life.”
Sure, they’re contrived, but they carry
lessons relevant to useful problems you may
actually need to solve one day.
Maybe it seems silly to liken this windmill
puzzle to a fairytale; a mathematical Aesop
summarizing that the moral of the story is
to seek quantities which stay constant.
But some of you watching this will one day
face a problem where finding an invariant
reveals a slick solution, and you might even
look like a genius for doing so.
If a made-up windmill prepares you for a real
problem, who cares that it’s a fiction?